[Music]
with our sport we're tested a lot for
what we have just make sure we're not
consume any banned substances or doping
or anything and there have definitely
been a lot of issues out there where
people have taken just normal
supplements and pop positive not
intentionally just because one of their
products wasn't safe so for me it's very
important to have a product that I can
depend on so science and sport checks
that off of me science and sports
testing process is world leading having
the informed sport certification is
really important to me because as an
athlete I practice clean sport all the
time I like to think that my competitors
are practicing that as well
having the certification gives me more
confidence when I use the product
because I know that's something I don't
have to worry about I take you saw that
anti-doping very seriously and having a
product I know is clean to put into my
body is something I really find
important I know I'm taking a clean
product and I can be at peace and not be
stressed in any sense that's a huge
thing for me with science the sport that
I love about it
you